it was interesting with Clinton to be
able to work on this sort of emotional
breakdown that Rick is having this
realization that time has passed him by
Jesus I had a lot of discussions about
whether you know these sort of pivotal
scenes with the young lady in the movie
who's kind of this young Meryl Streep
who's telling Rick hey things aren't
that bad by the way this other actress
he's talking about is nine right exactly
I told Leo about this show from like the
early 70s that I was a big fan of and
actually Brad was a big fan of when we
were both kids Alia Smith and Jones and
I told him about the actor P Duel who
was on the show and somewhere in the
second season he committed suicide I did
a little bit of research and found out a
little bit that he had a bit of a
drinking problem it sounds like the guy
was undiagnosed bipolar and he had mood
swings and the reason that he was
drinking was to self-medicate himself
Leo got that [ __ ] drinking again a
goddamn [ __ ] whiskey sours yeah we
never say the words that he's bipolar
it's just look I think he said it the
best it possibly could be